we've got a few more molecular
structures to name so let's look at this
first one right here so the first thing
you always want to do is identify the
longest chain so if we start over here
we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 carbons looks pretty long now what if
we start over here this looks like it
could also be a long chain
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13. so we
have two different chains depending on
whether whether we want to go up here or
whether we go over here that have a
length of 13 so you're probably asking
which chain do you choose and you should
always if you have two chains of equal
length and they're the longest chains
you pick the one that will have more uh
branches or more alkyl groups on it so
this group right here if we pick this
kind of from here to here as our chain
we only have one group on it that group
up there if we pick this chain
starting over here and then going over
here we have two groups on it we would
have this group over here and then we
would have
and then we would have this group
this group
over here
so this is the better chain to use
because it has more groups on it has
more groups but the groups are smaller
and simpler
so let's start counting and the
direction we want to count we always
want to start on the side of the chain
where we're going to encounter something
first and everything is closer to this
end of the chain so we'll start counting
here
we'll start counting here
one
two
three
four
13. so we have 13 carbons on our main
chain let me draw our main chain so our
main chain is this thing in orange
i'm drawing right here that is our main
chain
it's like that 13 that's 3 and 10 the
prefix is tri-deck and it's try decane
because we have all single bonds here so
it is tridekin
tridekane is the main chain and then we
have two groups over here this one in
green this only has one carbon branching
off of the main chain so its prefix will
be meth then it will be a methyl group
so that is methyl
that is a methyl group right there and
then this one down here we have one two
three carbons the prefix is probe so
this is a propyl group
this is a propyl group
pro
pill group and
this is the methyl is sitting on the
three carbon the methyl is sitting on
the three carbon of our main chain and
the propyl group is sitting on the four
carbon one two three four now when we
figure out what order to list them in
when we actually write out the name m we
just do it in alphabetical order m
comes before p so we write 3-methyl
before 4-propyl so the entire compound
here is or the entire molecule is
3
three
methyl
three methyl
four propyl four propyl
tridecane
4-propyl tridecane
trideca
and this is actually all going to be one
word if you don't you use dash to
separate when you have numbers but if
you have a word followed by a word it
just becomes purple trideking so
3-methyl 4-propyl tridecane and we're
done let's do this one down here now
this one seems a little bit more complex
so the first thing to see is what is the
largest chain or the largest ring that
we have in our structure
and the two candidates we have this
chain over here this has one two three
four five six
seven
carbons let's see how many carbons our
ring has our ring
our ring has one two three four five six
seven eight nine carbon so the ring is
the largest i guess you could say core
structure in this molecule so that will
be our that will that will be our core
structure and so we have nine carbons
let me highlight it so the ring
the ring is this right here
has nine carbons the prefix 4 9 is non
it's all single bonds so it's non-aine
and it is in a cycle it's a ring so it's
cyclonine so this part right here that
part right there is cyclonine cycloneine
and then we have several things that
branch off of the cyclone so let's look
at them one at a time and then we'll
think about how we're going to number
them on the ring
so we looked already at this at this
chain that has seven carbons one two
three four let me do that other blue i
like the other blue better one two three
four five six
seven
so that is a heptal group
heptil group
now this over here let's see what we're
dealing with we have one
two
three carbons so that is just a standard
propyl group
so this is just a standard propyl group
and then here
here we have
we have one two
three four carbons so we could say this
is a butyl group but this isn't just any
butyl group if we use the common naming
the carbon we immediately touch on or
that we immediately get to when we go
off of our main ring that branches off
into three other carbons so this is tert
tert for three so this is and the tert
is usually written in italics it's hard
to differentiate that when you see it
when you see it i'll write it in uh
i'll write it in cursive
tert this is tert this is a
tert butyl group
now the next question is how do we
specify where these different groups sit
on this main ring now if you just had
one if you just said one group you
wouldn't have to specify but when you
have more than one what you actually do
is you figure out which one would be
alphabetically first and that would be
number one
now we have an h in heptal a p in propyl
and tert butyl you might say well do i
use the t or do i use the b and this is
just the convention you use the bee if
you have sec butyl or tert butyl you
ignore the the sec or the tert if this
was an isobutyl or an isopropyl you
actually would use the eye so it's a
little bit you i guess the best way to
think about it there's a dash here so
you can kind of ignore it but if this is
isobutyl it would all be one word so you
would consider the i so in this
situation we would consider the b
and b comes before p
or an h so that is where we will start
numbering one and then to figure out
which direction to keep numbering in we
just go in the direction where we're
likely to encounter the first or we will
encounter the first chain the first side
chain so we'll go in this direction
because we get right to the proper group
one two
three
four
five
six seven
eight nine so this compound we're going
to start with the alphabetically first
side chain so it's one tert-butyl
it's one
tert let me write that in cursive let me
get some more space here so it is one
i'll write this in cursive tert
tert
butyl
one tert butyl then the next one
alphabetically is the heptyl group
that's h for heptal so then it is five
heptal
five
heptal and then we have the propyl
and then it is two propyl
two
propyl
two propyl and then finally cyclonine
cycloning
cycloneine
and we're done